laurent alexandre bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france alors on le voit le torchon
brûle entre bruxelles et le laboratoire
astrazeneca notamment qu'est ce que ça
révèle finalement un manque de rigueur
évident dans la rédaction des contrats
entre les différents laboratoires et
l'union européenne
l'échec total de la stratégie
bruxelloise quand vous regardez bien les
grands pays occidentaux modernes les
états unis l'angleterre et puis israël
ont beaucoup de doses ont négocié très
précocément ont négocié très précisément
et ont un nombre quasi illimité de doses
c'est la raison pour laquelle on en
angleterre en dépasse désormais 10 % de
vaccination alors qu'on est à 2% dans
l'union européenne
israël ayant dépassé 48 vaccination pour
100 habitants
donc il y a un énorme retard de l'union
européenne qui est le 13 ans en arrière
par rapport aux autres pays
donc ce n'est pas un problème spécifique
à un laboratoire pharmaceutique
bruxelles a mal négocié avec tous les
laboratoires stéphane bancel le
président de modern a expliqué dans la
presse récemment
razer a expliqué qu' il y a il y avait
des pays qui avaient été plus proactifs
et qui avait négocié plus tôt donc c'est
une vraie crise de la gouvernance
bruxelloise
donc il faut il faut il faut noter par
exemple que benjamin netanyahu le
premier ministre israélien a passé dix
sept coups de téléphone personnel au
président de pfizer pour sécuriser ces
doses la présidente de la commission n'a
pas appelé 17 fois les présidents de
laboratoire pour avoir les vaccins
donc finalement premier à commander
premier servi c'est logique dans la
situation sanitaire mondiale que nous
répond que nous vivons l'été dernier
l'union européenne s'est endormie elle
n'a quasiment pas négociées avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques en 2 juin à
septembre
elle s'est réveillée extrêmement
tardivement real a commandé les doses
plusieurs mois après les autres pays
elle s'étonne aujourd'hui de ne pas être
livrés alors effectivement pour l'union
c'est un camouflet énorme ça montre que
l'union européenne ne sait pas faire
certaines choses en l'occurrence
commander les vaccins
elle s'est laissé avoir et les doses
partent ailleurs il y a là une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur cet échec cinglant
de la gouvernance bruxelloise parce que
la réalité c'est que israël est de
l'angleterre et les états unis vaccine à
tour de bras et ont énormément de doses
et l'europe est face à une pénurie
majeure qui va poser des problèmes
politiques
on le voit aux pays bas où les gens se
révoltent
on peut le voir dans d'autres pays
européens les gens vont craquer si on
les consignes alors qu'on ne les
vaccinent pas parce que la réalité c'est
que dans les semaines qui viennent
il n'y aura quasiment pas de doses
vaccinales en europe et que donc
l'europe va continuer à prendre du
retard et va dès confiné bien après les
autres pays moderne qui eux ont
quasiment un nombre illimité de doses
vaccinales
alors il y avait désaccord sur la teneur
des accords justement entre les
laboratoires et et l'union européenne
est ce que ces contrats doivent être
rendus publics pour vous
s'il est prévu que les contrats ne
soient pas publics il ne doivent pas
être rendus publics ce sont des contrats
de droit privé pas de droit public donc
on n'a aucune raison s'il est stipulé
qu'ils ne doivent pas être rendus
publics qu'ils le soient
le problème il est que ce que l'on voit
pragmatiquement c'est que les grands
pays vaccinent occidentaux alors que
l'union européenne n'arrive pas à
vacciner donc on peut prendre le
problème qu'on veut c'est un échec de
l'union européenne
les autres ont des doses et l'union
européenne n'a pas de dose
donc comment en avoir dans le futur
eh bien ça va être extrêmement difficile
il très peu probable que l'union
européenne réussissent à avoir des doses
dans les semaines dans les mois qui
viennent
donc il va falloir gérer une pénurie
longue l'europe doit se préparer à des
couvre-feux et des consignes mans
pendant de longs mois
alors que d'autres pays vont sortir des
mesures de limitation de liberté plus
vite alors justement aussi à chaque pays
se confine chacun de son côté ce qui va
pas y avoir désormais une tentation pour
les pays membres de l'union européenne
va d'obtenir soi même ses vaccins
écoutez vu la façon dont la commission a
mal négocié il est logique que les pays
cherchent des doses de toute façon ce
que l'on voit c'est que l'union
européenne contrairement à certains
pays n'a pas voulu payer à son juste
prix les doses c'est pour ça qu'elle en
a moins aussi on voit aujourd'hui qu'on
aurait mieux fait de payer les doses
plus cher pour en avoir davantage
et quand on regarde le coût
psychologique du confinement le coût
économique du confinement
le coût humain et médical du confinement
on se rend compte qu'on aurait pu payer
les doses 1000 2000 3000 euros et
l'union européenne aurait quand même été
gagnante parce que cela aurait avancé le
déconfinement beaucoup cela aurait
relancé l'économie plutôt et et le
confinement coûte des milliards à
l'union européenne chaque chaque jour et
puis cela aurait sauvé des milliers dit
donc la stratégie de l'union européenne
de chipoter sur les doses et de signer
les contrats très tardivement conduit
juste à ce que l'europe sacrifie des
milliers d'ici et sacrifient des
centaines de milliards de richesses et
détruisent beaucoup d'emplois parce
qu'elle va des consignes et après les
autres alors il ya là anglais qui s'est
elle tournée vers la russie pour une
commande de vaccins scouts ni lever
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait faire
effet boule de neige dans certains pays
de l'union européenne
je ne suis pas sûr que des gens comme
emmanuel macron marque ou merkel aux
contourner l'union européenne dans la
situation actuelle je pense que le plus
probable c'est plutôt que l'union
européenne va gérer la pénurie pendant
plusieurs mois en expliquant qu'elle a
raison et que les laboratoires sont
méchants alors qu'en réalité des
laboratoires ne sont pas méchants
c'est l'union européenne qui s'est
complètement planté pour le dire
vulgairement et elle pourrait elle
prendre des sanctions l'union européenne
on entend un petit peu murmure et cette
idée là en des sanctions contre les
laboratoires c'est quelque chose qui
serait possible entendu selon je crois
que le problème n'est pas du ressort des
sanctions je pense que c'est une leçon
l'union européenne a signé après les
autres n'a pas travaillé pendant que les
autres travaillé d'arrache-pied pour
avoir des doses union européenne aurait
dû imiter boris johnson ou le premier
ministre netanyahou voir les états unis
au lieu d'avoir la stratégie brouillonne
qu'elle a eue ce plantage est absolument
invraisemblable et son coût pour l'union
européenne va être énorme
le couple
les malades et mais aussi le coût pour
l'économie je suis un soleil très déçu
en tant que pro européen de la tournure
de cette crise et l'union européenne va
chercher un bouc émissaire à ses erreurs
c'est normal et le bouc émissaire ce
sera les laboratoires mais ce que l'on
voit c'est que d'autres pays qui ont
mieux négocié qui ont négocié plus tôt
ont eu les doses et l'union européenne
elle n'a pas eu les doses et c'est ça le
grave problème pour les pays de l'union
aujourd'hui et cette stratégie vaccinale
justement est-ce qu'elle va pas être mis
totalement à plat parce qu'on le
rappelle il faut deux doses pour que le
vaccin fonctionne
est ce qu'on va pouvoir réussir à
vacciner tout le monde avec ses 2 doses
dans les temps impartis
et bien il y à des endroits où on va
reporter la deuxième dose et on n'est
pas certain que de reculer jusqu'à 12
semaines la deuxième injection n'est pas
de conséquence sur l'immunité
on craint qu'il puisse y avoir une
baisse de l'immunité au bout de quelques
mois
si mon espace les les deux doses et le
le plus important à mon avis est que
certains pays vont craquer le pinier on
en a marre d'être d'être confiné et moi
je suis assez inquiet quand on voit ce
qui se passe dans un pays d'habitude
extrêmement calme les pays bas avec des
émeutes depuis plusieurs jours on se dit
que cette situation pourrait arriver
dans d'autres pays moi je suis très
inquiet de la réaction de l'opinion
quand l'opinion publique européenne va
réaliser qu'il n'y a pas de dose parce
que l'union a mal négocié
j'ai peur qu'il ay à des réactions
violentes parce que je ne suis pas du
tout certain que les citoyens de l'union
européenne soient enchantés de rester
sous couvre-feu ou sous confinement
pendant des mois et des mois et des mois
à cause des erreurs de l'union
européenne était qu'est ce que vous
pensez justement de sanofi qui a dix qui
a déclaré vouloir aider le laboratoire
pfizer
c'est une blague sanofi va mettre en
flacon bva étiqueté le vaccin de pfizer
elle ne va absolument pas participé à la
production de vaccins c'est un effet
d'annoncé ridicule j'ai énormément de
respect pour le laboratoire sanofi mais
franchement mettre en bouteille et
mettre d'étiquette sur les flacons ça ne
va absolument pas faire avancer le
schmilblick
c'est assez pathétique est assez
grotesque
en france l'institut pasteur qui
abandonne son projet le vaccin à cela
s'ajoute le retard pris par le vaccin
développé par sanofi on en parlait à
l'instant à ce que s'il ya une vraie
question là qui se posent à propos de la
de la dépendance française par rapport à
tous ces vaccins
une chose est sûre la france n'investit
pas assez dans la recherche
elle investit moins que les pays les
plus avancés
elle dépense de 21 % de la richesse
nationale en recherche a alors que des
pays comme israël et la corée du sud
sont pas loin de 5%
donc il y a un retard en matière de
recherche en biotechnologies en france
et puis la france a fait partir un
certain nombre de ces grands chercheurs
c'est le cas de bananes charpentier la
prix nobel de médecine l'inventeur des
des ciseaux moléculaires qui d'ailleurs
quand elle a voulu revenir en france en
2012 n'a pas trouvé de poste en france
le gouvernement n'a pas daigné lui
trouver un poste de chercheur alors
qu'elle souhaitait se rapprocher de ses
vieux parents qui étaient qui était
malade
donc la france un problème avec la
recherche est là un problème avec la
recherche en biotechnologie l'institut
pasteur n'a pas assez d'argent le but
est d'asseoir bester est extrêmement
faible
donc il c'est l'occasion ces deux échecs
de réfléchir à la stratégie de recherche
française et notamment de recherche en
biotechnologie cela dit que des
laboratoires échoue dans le
développement d'un médicament ou des
vins d'un vaccin c'est normal il y à des
prises de risques importantes quand on
essaie un nouveau procédé quand on ne
décèle nouvelles technologies il ne faut
pas blâmer sanofi pasteur
mais il faut que la france investisse
davantage dans la recherche en général
et dans la recherche en biotechnologie
là le salaire moyen des chercheurs en
france est absolument indécent il y a un
énorme effort de rattrapage à faire en
france
merci beaucoup laurent alexandre d'avoir
été avec nous dans la matinale de accès
france je le rappelle vous êtes
essayiste et médecins